- Who took a bite of this?
- (laughs collectively)
- Hey, I'm Kelly and I'm a
Culinary Producer at Tasty.
And this is my husband, Jeremy.
- Hi, I'm Jeremy and I'm a chef.
- And we have been cooking
together for 11 years?
- Yeah, that sounds about right.
- We met in culinary school.
Day one, he fell in love. I didn't.
- Wow.
- I'm joking.
- We have two wonderful
young boys, Dylan and Teddy,
and Dylan will be joining us today.
- [Producer] Are you nervous at all?
- No, I feel great.
- [Dylan] I'm nervous...
- Why? Cause you have to pick
between mommy and daddy, yeah.
- [Producer] Is there
any like challenge stakes
we could add to this?
- If I win, I would love
some help with the laundry
this whole seven loads a week thing
isn't working for me anymore.
Maybe split it up.
- Fine, okay. So what happens if I win?
- I'll wake up before 9:00 AM.
- Yeah, I wanna sleep in on the weekends.
- You got it.
- Okay. Deal.
For today's challenge,
I'm gonna be making a space
themed pizza lunch box.
We are going to start with easy,
peasy pizza dough in a can.
So I have this cute rocket
shaped cookie cutter.
I'm gonna cut out a few, kind of small.
I don't know how many stuff it with pizza.
All right, let's do one,
and then assess, if I have
to change my game plan.
So this is just store bought pizza sauce.
Again, store bought is fine.
They don't care.
So I'm just gonna put like
the teeniest little amount
and then I'm gonna add some cheese.
And then I found these
little baby pepperonis
that I thought were so cute.
Now I'm just gonna wash the
outer part, the outer like rim,
so I can stick another piece
on top and glue it together.
Kind of just looks like a Christmas tree.
It definitely lost its shape.
That's okay. That's okay.
Alright. I also have this rocket.
Maybe this will look better.
Okay. This one's cute.
All right, so I'm just gonna brush the top
with egg wash to get it nice and crispy.
And then I was just gonna
put a little Parmesan on top.
So it's like half pizza,
half cheesy breadstick.
And then maybe I should
make a little window.
Okay. So I'm gonna bake these at 425°,
I think for like eight to
10 minutes, but we'll see.
I wanted to recreate those
like little pudding packs
but I wanted to make a healthier version.
It's called ABC pudding,
avocado, banana, and cacao.
And then I'm gonna call it galaxy pudding
and dye some whipped
cream, blue and purple,
and swirl it on top.
So it's like outer space theme,
but a little bit healthier.
First thing, A is avocado.
I could not find any good
avocados at the store.
So I actually found these frozen ones.
So they look pretty green.
So we're gonna add those in
and it'll probably give it
like a nice texture that it's frozen.
Add one banana.
And then the C is cocoa powder
which is where the chocolate comes in.
Dylan has the biggest sweet tooth.
He asks for cookies
and cake every morning.
I have to tell him it's
not a breakfast food.
So I think he'll be
really excited about this.
And then just to sweeten it up
I'm gonna add some maple syrup.
I'm gonna add a little bit of milk
just to like help it blend together.
And then how easy was that?
We're just gonna blend it up.
(blender whirring)
(amplified blender whirring)
That's perfect.
He is gonna love this.
This might be my winning star.
The next step I'm gonna do for my lunchbox
is add some fruit and veggies.
Just to add some balance to
the pizza and the pudding.
So I'm just gonna cut some thick slices
and then take my star cookie cutter.
Look how cute!
Then for the bell pepper
I was actually thinking
it could be like the
fire, the gas, what is it?
So I'm just gonna cut it in
thin strips then maybe in half
and then like, here's the rocket ship,
and then I'll put 'em
underneath like that.
Carrots too. Dylan loves
carrots and hummus.
So we got our veggies.
Now let's move on to the fruit.
Look how juicy that is.
First, I'm just gonna cut some circles.
I mean, I guess it's a full moon
but maybe I should make it a little cuter.
Cute.
Okay, I wanted to create
some type of Martian alien
to go with the space theme.
So I found this little cheese
and I'm gonna pull the wax off,
and then cut it down the middle.
And then I'm gonna use
some marshmallow fluff
to glue on some eyes.
Kind of like the Toy Story Martian.
I've never done this, but we'll see.
I just have to tell Dylan
he can't eat the wax.
I don't know, do they look like aliens?
Like? Maybe?
Maybe, if I can like put
some toothpicks in his head.
So I need to make a planet and
green is his favorite color.
So I'm gonna take a Tootsie Roll Lollipop
and put a ring around it, to make Saturn.
That's cute...
...right?
No? (laughs)
To make like the green antennas
I'm gonna take some green apple
and little strips and
then stick it in the top.
It kinda looks like a rabbit.
It looks like a three eyed rabbit.
Let's just move on.
What do I have next?
I gotta make the ranch dip, the best part.
Okay, so we're just
gonna put some sour cream
and I'm going old school
with the ranch packet
because you cannot beat this flavor.
Even as a chef, I know I've
made ranch a million times.
It never tastes like this ever, ever.
When I worked in a restaurant
and when I was a waitress,
I was in charge of making the ranch.
People were always asking for the recipe
and I'm like (laughs) it's
on the back of the package.
Okay, I'll put this in the fridge
and then move on to the next step.
All right, we're onto the last step.
I'm gonna make the galaxy whipped cream
to go onto our healthy pudding.
So I'm just gonna take some heavy cream.
I'm gonna add just a little bit of
powdered sugar to sweeten it.
And then I'm just gonna beat this
with a hand mixer on high speed
until medium to stiff peaks form.
Those are stiff peaks.
Little bit of purple.
Ooh, this is like a neon
purple. This is fun.
Okay, so we got purple done.
Now let's add blue.
I was a little bit nervous
the food dye would mess
with the texture of the whipped cream,
but it's actually working out.
Okay, all right, and now
we're gonna do the fun part.
We're gonna go to the assembly.
First, I'm going to add my rocket ship
and then I'm gonna add some bell peppers
and some carrots coming off the end,
so it looks like it's
that fire spurting out.
I have my star cucumbers and
then I also have my mango moons
with some blueberries cause
I know Dylan Love those.
So now I have my alien Martains
We're still not sure about
these, but they're cute.
They're cute.
Okay. The best part, our healthy pudding.
Look at those fun colors.
He's gonna love that. He's gonna love it.
And then for the all star,
I found these outer space themed sprinkles
and finally our little Saturn lollipop.
And that's it.
(spacey, sci-fi music)
- So today I will be cooking
a superhero themed lunch.
I will be making a
Captain America burrito,
Captain America rice crispy treats,
little Spider-man strawberries,
and the hammers of Thor
using cheese and pretzel sticks.
At home, we call Dylan "Captain America"
because he protects his little brother
who we call 'Iron Man'.
So I think this one will
go over well with him.
So first for the Rice Krispy treats,
we're gonna melt some butter,
the more fat the better.
So now that the butter's melted,
I'm just gonna add in the marshmallows.
Now that our marshmallow and
butter are nice and smooth
and all mixed together, we
will add the Rice Krispies.
I'm just gonna mix it all together
until all forms one ball
and then we'll get it cooling down.
All right, now they're all mixed together,
and we'll start cooling them down,
so we could shape them into
balls and into shields.
So normally if I was
gonna Rice Krispy treats,
I would flatten this out
and try to compress it.
But since we're just
rolling it into balls,
I'll just pop it into the fridge like this
and let it cool down.
Now that they're cooled down,
I could add some sprinkles.
If you add them while they're still warm,
the color will be bleed into them.
And you'll just kind of have a brown mess
and then shape them
into balls and shields.
And now we're gonna mix the sprinkles
into the Rice Krispy treats.
Now, once they're mixed in,
we are just gonna roll
it into a little ball
and then flatten it out
to look like a shield.
We're just gonna use a whole cutter
and punch out the center
to represent the star on his shield.
So next we are going to
make Spider-man faces out of
strawberries, chocolate
chips and marshmallow fluff.
So this is really simple.
All we're gonna do is
slice the strawberries.
So now we have our face.
Next, we will place two
chocolate chips as the eyes,
try to wedge them in there.
And then we're gonna shape
those eyes with the white
to kind of make it look
like Spider-man's eyes.
Okay, now we have small strawberries
that vaguely look like Spider-man.
Next we're gonna cut cubes
out of a block of cheese
for Thor's hammer and put
pretzel sticks into the box.
So make it look like a big hammer.
So next up, I'm going
to try to make the fist
of the Incredible Hulk.
The Hulk wears purple pants.
So I'm going to take vanilla
yogurt and purple food coloring
and mix that together
and then use green grapes
to form a fist on top
of the purple yogurt.
Kind of. (chuckles)
So next we are going to make
our Captain America burrito.
And since there aren't many
burrito friendly foods that come
in the color blue, and we
want red, white, and blue.
We're gonna add a little
bit of blue food coloring
to our mozzarella cheese.
I'm going to add a little
salsa to my red beans,
just to give it a little more red color,
and to give a little more flavor.
Cause Dylan does love salsa.
The first layer we're
gonna add is the rice
and the rice is already white,
so we don't have to add any color to that
for the red, white, and blue theme.
After the rice, we'll
add in our red beans.
And then we'll top the whole thing off
with the blue cheese and roll it up.
So now that our burritos rolled,
we're just gonna sear it off in the pan
to get the cheese nice and melty
and the burrito all sealed up.
And now we're just gonna
cut into the burrito
and hopefully have red, white,
and blue for Captain America.
Next we're gonna make little
spiderwebs out of string cheese
to put underneath the strawberries,
and then we're gonna assemble everything
and put it into the box.
Top those are a couple of
our Spider-man strawberries.
Next we will pipe in some hummus
into our lightning bolt mold.
And then we'll put the
Thor hammers around that.
Now we have our already
assembled Hulk hands.
We're just gonna drop this in here.
We're going to add a
little bit of guacamole
for the burrito.
Next we'll add our burrito.
Can't forget our Captain America dessert.
And last, just to keep
with the superheroes,
we'll add our little guys.
So he knows who he's looking at.
And this is the superhero lunch.
(triumphant, upbeat music)
- Hmm, strawberry. I don't
know how to get them out.
I got it.
Juicy, now I want...
Avocado
- [Kelly] (laughs) Dylan.
- [Woman] What is it, you don't like it?
- I like it.
- [Producer] Did that rice
crispy remind you of anything?
- No.
- (laughs)
- Can I have the next one?
Hm. The moon.
Can I take his eyes off?
This is a cold rocket ship.
- It's what?
What was your favorite
thing out of both of these?
- The strawberries and the alien.
- Oh, the alien?
You liked that cheese.
Did you like your pizza?
- I didn't know that was pizza.
- Because it was cold?
Some people like cold pizza, Dyl.
- I don't.
(Kelly and Jeremy laugh)
- All right, we have a
tough question to ask you.
- What?
- Which one was your favorite?
- Ahhh...
Mommy's.
- Yay.
Look at you
Yay.
What made it the best?
The lollipop?
- Yeah.
- Looks like mommy's
sleeping in this weekend.
- (laughs) Oh, right? I forgot.
- And that means you get to
help me with the laundry.
- No.
- (in unison) Thanks for having me.